التحضيرات لعيد ميلاد الملك تشارلز الرسمي
في 17 يونيو شغاله على قدم وساق في
بريطانيا طبعا قلت عيد ميلاد او عيد ميلاد
الرسمي لانه في بريطانيا بيحتفلوا بعيد
ميلاد الملك مرتين مره في يوم الميلاد
الفعلي وفي حاله الملك تشارلز هو 14
نوفمبر ومره رسميا في تاريخ 17 يونيو اللي
صار ضف موعد عرض عسكري سنوي اسمه
المهم مو هنا الخبر ترى هذه المقدمه بس
امس وخلال حضور امير ويلز ولي عهد
بريطانيا الامير ويليام الاخيره للحفل سقط
ثلاث جنود على الارض مغمى عليهم والسبب
درجات الحراره العاليه اللي وصلت ل 30
درجه مئويه ايوه على فكره في بريطانيا 30
تعتبر درجات حراره يعني عاليه هذا موضوع
اخر على جنب نتناقش فيه في يوم ثاني يعني
على العموم هذا غير انهم طبعا هم لابسين
ثقيل جدا وطواقي من الجلد واقفين ساعات
عفوا طواقي من الفرو ووقتين ساعات
[موسيقى]
مسكين اللي صح على الارض ورجع وقف وكمل
عزف ومثل ما شفتوا مشاهدينا اللي بيطيح ما
بيقرب عليه احد من زملائه الانقاذ بيجي من
برا من عناصر مو مشاركين في العرض وهذا
جزء من البروتوكول ومو اول مره نشوف مقاطع
او لحظات من هذا النوع خاصه
[موسيقى]
في جنازه الملكه اليزابيثوا في حوادث اخرى
شفناها ايضا امام القصور
[موسيقى]